الى كوريا الشماليه الان تظهر هناك مجددا
ابنه كينغ اون الزعيم تظهر الى جانبه خلال
اطلاق
باقوى صاروخ استراتيجيه في العالم ظهور هو
الثاني للفتاه بعد ان ظهرت للمره الاولى
الاسبوع الماضي معه
ثلاثه اولاد الاول ذكر والثانيه والثالثه
من الاناناس في حين ان من ظهرت معه هي
الابنه الوسطى ويعتقد انها ولدت عام 2013
وصفت وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه
الفتاه بانها الاكثر قربا الى قلبكن
والطفله العزيزه ومحبوبه وهي الوحيده من
اولاده التي ظهرت في شكل رسمي
ظهور المتكرر يثير تكهنات طبعا بانه يتم
اعداد الفتاه لتكون خليفه لوالدها بالضبط
كما كان يتم اعداده هو ليخلف والده الزعيم
الراحل
ان ذاك كان كيم لا يزال صغيرا لكن حصل على
القاب كبيره بدات بالرفيق اللامع حتى وصل
الى المرشد الاعلى للبلاد بعد وفاه والده
بينما يقول ينجم الاستاذ في جامعه دراسات
كوريا الشماليه في سول ان وجود ابنتي يهدف
الى تصوير صاروخ الجديد الذي
سيتم اطلاقه على انه حلم جيل المستقبل
عده ليستخدمها في الدعايه لقوه نظامه
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاحتفاليه لاطلاق الصاروخ اكد
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي ان بلاده تعتزم ان
تكون اقوى قوه استراتيجيه في العالم من
اجل حمايه كرامه الدوله
على الوصول الى القوه المطلقه التي لم
يسبق لها اي مثيل في القرن الذي نعيش فيها
وكاله الانباء الرسميه اكدت ان عمليه
الاطلاق تلك اثبتت للعالم بوضوح ان كوريا
الشماليه هي قوه نوويه بالكامل كذلك اطلقت
الوكاله سما الوحش على الصاروخ الجديد
وقالت انه قادر على الوصول الى الاراضي
الامريكيه لكن كوريا الشماليه قادره على
الوصول للاراضي الامريكيه بالفعل وذلك
15 الذي اطلقته عام 2017 تذكرون اننا
نتحدثنا عنه كثيرا
لكن يبدو ان الهدف من الصاروخ الجديد هو
اثبات ان كوريا الشماليه هي اقوى دوله
تمتلك صواريخ بالستيا عابره للقارات
اللافت ان هذه التطورات تاتي بعد دعوه
الرئيس الصيني لزعيم كوريا الشماليه
بالتعاون من اجل تسريع السلام في العالم
حيث اكد الرئيس الصيني
ان العالم يتغير بشكل غير مسبوق وانه
مستعد للتعاون معكم بشكل ايجابي لتحقيق
السلامه في المنطقه قبل نحوي اسبوعين
حينما التقى الرئيس الامريكي الرئيس
الصيني طلبه ايضا بابلغه كوريا الشماليه
بوضوح بضروره عدم اجراء تجربه نوويه جديده
يبدو ان رساله
الى زعيم كوريا الشماليه ويبدو ان الاخير
ايضا لم يهتم بها كثيرا
[موسيقى]